his has historically been uh
anti-American and anti-semitic here with
reaction Hoover institution senior
fellow Victor Davis Hansen you know
Victor I'm kind of a Paleo guy I'm a I'm
a keto guy I'm I eat meat and I eat a
lot of eggs and I eat as few carbs as
possible um I'm not willing to cooperate
sorry I'm not either they're one red
meat and dairy are one of the richest
sources of protein calcium B vitamins
vitamin D magnesium they're very healthy
and we know that we during the co
epidemic a lot of people felt that a
high protein meat diet was essential to
restore and get a robust immune system
but what's behind this is this golden
idea that climate change that govern all
of our Lives man-made uh climate change
that we can address through radical
utopian bromides whether it's Banning
gas stoves or getting rid of the ranch
Suburban house and prettiness and
highrise surrendering your car so you
got on mass transit and part of that is
we can't have beef anymore because they
feel that it it cattle contribute to
global warming but there's no there's no
evidence for any of this other than a
dislike of the modern American middle
class lifestyle and that's what it's
about and believe me the B Coastal
Elites that dictate from on high are
never subject to the consequences of
their own ideology we saw that with a
recent picture of Cala Harrison or gas
stove and the same thing be true of Fine
Meats uh same thing let me ask you this
is it time Victor Davis Hansen I've been
saying this for a long time uh I am not
a fan of these globalist organizations I
don't want as far as I'm concerned I
would say the UN can go leave maybe
China can take them on uh they could
support them with billions of dollars
and we don't have to pay um I'm tired of
the WF I'm I'm tired of the wh that lied
to us about co uh the Paris Accords are
at asinine and we're paying the bulk of
of monies China pays next to nothing
they're quote characterized and and
categorized as a developing Nation like
India it's insane isn't it time for
America to rethink
this yeah I think it is I think we
should have if we're going to have one
international organization it should be
an organization of constitutional
consensual Democratic Republican states
but that's not what the UN is we October
7th was a scab that was torn over and we
looked at the UN again and my God Iran
has just been appointed to the chair of
the uh UN Human Rights Forum Iran who's
who's at the center of all this violence
in the Middle East and then we had the
Secretary General said yes it was
horrific on October 7 but we have to
have context that's like saying you know
Pearl Harbor you know that was a
surprise attack but before we respond we
have to have context and so it's a
bankrupt organization that's not subject
to any audit most of the 100 180 or 90
members never have a vote unless they
get to New York that's the first and
only time these members participate in
participatory democracy so yeah I think
we should get it out at least get it out
of New York and put it in the Middle
East maybe or Africa or Latin America
well because they are as I've said
historically been very anti-semitic very
anti-American Victor Davis Sanson great
to see you thank you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else